jean reno bourse ou pas bon apparemment
ça fonctionne bien
oui ça marche bien c'est un grand film
et vous êtes sûr on va rire autant que
sur le premier ça je ne sais pas ce que
le premier était quand même assez plus
que comique était jubilatoire celui là
je sais qu'il est comique est beaucoup
plus grand du fait des informations de
l'histoire qu'on a récolté du premier
qui est puisque c'est la suite de
l'histoire n'est ce pas on recommence
exactement à la fin du premier et donc
on a plus d'informations les auteurs en
plus d'informations les acteurs et les
personnages voient se l'est vu il ya
deux jours puisque en fait de faire le
film a été fini de monter ah oui oui à
settat et j'ai vu un grand film
j'ai beaucoup ri j'avais la même
impression au premier j'avais rivera je
savais pas que c'était un film
jubilatoire ça j'ai découvert avec le
public et muriel robin après valérie
lemercier ça casse pas le ton un peu de
ce film et que la série l'homme comme
une histoire commence exactement à la
fin de l'autre si vous voulez je n'ai
pas vu ce passage très honnêtement elle
est là elle et ça démarre au moyen-âge
elle est là avec ses coiffes et puis paf
c'est frénégonde quoi plus que plus
qu'autre chose pour moi je crois que le
film est plus fort que les acteurs
saison et je pense la question que
j'aurais peut-être dû vous poser en
premier c'est est ce que le film sortira
bien mercredi parce que vous avez fini
effectivement sur les chapeaux de roue
et on faisait allusion aux ennuis de
dernière minute qui ont empêché
notamment beaucoup de gens de le voir
villégier non mais sérieux on l'a vu
parce que comme il faut qu'on en parle
il fallait bien qu'on voie un moment
donné puis je marie nous la présenter
mais ce que je sais c'est que le
laboratoire a tourné 24 heures sur 24
puisqu'il faut tirer 500 copies et en ce
moment on parle mais les copies ce tir
parce que c'est une opération qui dure
plusieurs jours ça d'habitude là c'est
ça exagéré les problèmes de mixage de
musique c'est pour ça qu'on aime bien
mais parce qu'il y avait des effets
spéciaux qui sont arrivés au dernier
moment et donc le mit dem xhc feu
dernier moment vous êtes aussi en
tournage à paris en ce moment vous
n'êtes pas trop difficile pour un seul
homme
assumer et la sortie d'un film très
attendu puisqu'on l'attend effectivement
et ce tournage lors grâce à dieu c'est
dimanche donc je vais venir vous voir et
merci de me recevoir
non mais je tourne avec de niro un film
de frankenheimer et c'est vrai que là
mercredi approche et je suis assez
nerveux
c'est vrai qu'ils soient contents ça se
passe bien avec de niro j'imagine très
bien avec tous les américains de façon
générale vous seriez connaissez vous
appréciez disque chez un acteur cool je
sais pas exactement ce que ça veut dire
mais en tout cas oui ça marche bien je
n'ai pas trop parler cet aspect là des
choses est de votre carrière c'est pas
une parenthèse quand même l' aventure
avec le cinéma américain
non là en ce moment évidemment ça prend
des proportions un peu plus fort puisque
j'ai fait l'été dernier godzilla avec
les gens qui ont fait une dépanneuse t
on va voir mais je ne partirai pas quoi
si c'est la question c'est ça je
resterai ici mais mon pays c'est la
france ça c'est clair on va on va
revenir un instant effectivement sur sur
les visiteurs de pardon les couloirs du
le tournage effectivement dans la vue
quelques images s'est promené un peu et
partout il y avait une réflexion j'avais
lu et entendu les legends connaissez par
coeur les rayonnages les répliques qui
font penser qu'effectivement il ya une
série qui vient de se créer
qu'obligatoirement il y aura un numéro 3
par exemple
je ne sais pas seulement on aura
j'allais dire avec le public la semaine
qui vient
mais en tout cas ce que je peux dire que
j'ai été très étonné abbaye nadja tôt
qu'on a vu qu'un château magnifiquement
conservés et qui est assez visité du 12e
siècle on a construit autour un petit
peu de décor autour de la basse cour et
les gens découper les morceaux du décor
bleu pour l'emporter à la maison quoi
ces petits morceaux là est donc là vous
vous dites c'est que vraiment le film a
vraiment beaucoup plus quoi jubilatoire
un phénomène quelque part oui ces six
énormes j'ai été assez magique ne sais
pas si ça va recommencer mais en tout
cas pour nous ça a été magique à ce
moment là merci jean reno nous avoir
rendu les idées de sorties de coulisses
heures merci neige